hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who episode eight video
part 2 of the Zygon episode just careful
for spoilers if you haven't watched it
yet who knew that Osgood's first name
was petronella it sounds a lot like
petrichor but real quick reminder new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's
just a $20 Amazon gift card so let's get
started whole bunch of Easter eggs for
the 50th anniversary in this top 5 WTF
starting with Clara wakes up inside the
dream there's this classic John
Carpenter movie called they live where
everybody wakes up and realizes that the
world has been taken over by aliens
that's what this was ripping on you
could also look at this is calling back
to souffle girl when Clara did not
realize that she was a Dalek most people
just remember that movie for Rowdy Roddy
Piper scenes he takes his sunglasses off
and says I came here to do two things
kick ass and chew bubblegum and I'm all
out of gum and then he has one of the
most epic street fights ever the Clark
is able to use the psychic bond that she
has with xyj Ella to try and keep her
from killing the doctor just giving him
enough time to escape communicate with
the doctor on a really low level and I'm
assuming at the end of the episode the
minutes I Gela became one of the new
Osgood's she stopped like she broke the
psychic bond with Clara it was a lot of
fun seeing Clara go up against Clara
they've actually been a lot of episodes
in the last two years that had put clara
against the doctor in one way or another
obviously the explanation here is that
it's Saigon's clara going up against the
doctor but i think knowing that there's
a ticking clock on Clara's time with the
doctor they just want to create some
emotional distance so that were open to
somebody else coming in and being the
new companion who is definitely not
going to be Osgood now on the number 4
Osgood in the doctor tried to help the
Zygon that was forced to normalize the
big WTF here is that he commits suicide
he just can't handle the radical Zygons
forcing him to live away that he does
not want to live you can view this as
discrimination for any type of special
interest group and anyone for many
different cultures any different sexual
orientation a group comes along and
forces them to live away they don't want
to live and it can drive them to suicide
this is probably about as political as
the episode got and I thought they were
subtle enough about it doctor who does
deal with real world social issues but I
think it tries not to beat you over the
head with
so that you notice them but they don't
overpower the story like it doesn't
become too preachy on the number three
though Kate Stewart is the real Kate
Stewart there's this big theme in the
episode about hybrids or you a human or
you Zygon but they wanted the Osgood
identity to be a big mystery but I think
they really wanted you to know ahead of
time what was going on with Kate Stewart
five rounds to the head that's actually
an Easter Egg for a classic episode
called the Damon's I think it was her
father that spoke that line and anytime
there's a unit episode they typically
refer back to the classic unit episodes
in some way or another and if you are a
big unit fan just go back and watch a
lot of third doctor episodes that was a
really big unit run on the number two
though let's make a deal so you're very
broad references here especially Capaldi
doing a really weird sounding American
type accent hearing that made me do a
double-take but this is all about the
50th anniversary pressing the button you
know just just remembering the giant red
button of the moment and then getting
back to Kate Stewart versus Kate Stewart
obviously this time it was versus
Nigella but it's the same sentiment and
I love the fact that as I jela figures
out there's nothing in the boxes the
boxes themselves are more of a teaching
device to get like whoever's trying to
blow the world up to figure out that
they shouldn't blow the world up it's
like the movie wargames the only way to
win is to not play and then the doctor
starts talking about how he did the same
thing with the time war I didn't press
the button but the difference with the
actual 50th anniversary when the war
doctor didn't press the button that
would have actually worked that bomb was
real these bombs are not in case you
missed it he said it only took 14 tries
to get it right that means that he wiped
their minds all that time until xyj ella
finally came around
at the end of the episode when the
doctor was like longest month of my life
and Clara said it was only five minutes
and he replied I'll be the judge of time
that was just a reference to the time
that Clara lost I think they really were
at it for a whole month
and the doctor just had to keep wiping
all their minds but finally on my number
one WTF moment the question that
everyone is asking are you human or are
you Saigon like the doctor and Kate
Stewart keep asking Osgood what she is
here's what I think is going on there
are a couple of different
interpretations if you if you take it
literally
then during series 8 Missy killed the
real Osgood it was meant to be this
really a mo
a moment for the fandom because she was
killing someone you love so if you're
taking that narrative literally then the
real Osgood died Saigon's Osgood kind of
became a hybrid because she was just she
was so intertwined with the mind of real
Osgood that she doesn't feel like a
Zygon anymore but she also kind of
remembers that she's not fully human so
that's why she's dodging the question
I'll tell you the answer when everyone
stops asking the question really what
the doctor wants to know and everyone
else is is the original Osgood still
alive and if this were the original
Osgood there'd be no reason to say
otherwise like she'd just come out and
say oh yeah yeah I'm the real Osgood I
didn't die don't worry the other
interpretation you take is the Moffat
lies interpretation like where he
reckons himself pulls a tiny bit from
the 50th anniversary and turns it into a
big plot device in a future episode he
has done that in past episodes where he
takes like a little detail from a
previous episode and turns it into a big
thing much much later the way I see it
is if you want this to be real Osgood
then that completely destroys the
emotional weight of Osgood dying during
series 8 so I believe that this is the
Zygon Osgood but I will concede that she
is something of a hybrid now just
because she was so connected to real
Osgood so she doesn't completely know
whether she's human or Zygon that is not
the case with xyj ella though we
definitely know there is a sigh Gela
Osgood and just to explain Osgood not
becoming the next companion that was
what that moment was about with the
doctor where she's like I have to stay
here I have a job to do so love it or
hate it no Osgood companion let me know
in the comments though here's the big
question do you think this is real
Osgood and Moffat lies or do you think
this is Zygon Osgood and Moffat isn't
completely destroying the emotional
moment that he wrote in to series 8 I
mentioned most of the Easter eggs
already but at the end of the episode
one of the Osgood's is wearing another
version of a Seventh Doctor costume
really my favorite Easter Egg though was
four they live it's such a classic
horror movie so you should definitely
check it out if you haven't seen it yet
but congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Boromir of Gondor you
win a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
info what's gonna happen next is is I'm
a little bit behind today I'm spending
some time with my friends they just got
married and raggedy man is late for
their wedding so I'm gonna try and get
an arrow flash supergirl video out then
there's Game of Thrones and walk
dead on Sunday hopefully all that we'll
post on time that that is definitely my
goal we'll see I might have to pull
another all-nighter we'll see as always
though I'll post updates on Facebook and
Twitter if you don't know where to find
me there there are links at the bottom
of the description lakeya's wait for
that to post you can click here for last
week's episode of Doctor Who and you can
click here for the warcraft trailer i
just posted and i posted an
international Star Wars trailer so
that'll like that'll open up a playlist
where you can see live stuff thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight